Jennifer Hudson performs during The
Voice Blind Auditions oh we gotta sing
something together cuz after that season
13 of The Voice kicked off on Monday
with some incredible performances but
the most epic of the night 26 year old
store clerk
Lucas Holliday who stunned the coaches
with a beautiful rendition of maxwell's
this woman's work
[Music]
first time coach Jennifer who turned
around for the Michigan native was
clearly surprised by his appearance why
is Fraser standing on the stage on
Saturday I mean what in the world
no offense cuz you're brilliant you're
like the whitest dude I know I'm
questioning the whole world right now
looks aside the American Idol alum was
so inspired by her new team member she
jumped on stage for a quick gospel duet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Maxwell that's one of my top influences
Maxwell tweeted shortly after Lucas's
performance giving him his seal of
approval writing from a session to this
woman's work
Lucas Holliday you have my support and
soul
[Music]
you